you know i'm going to see a friend in
orlando
um hopefully while i'm here in florida
who i put onto cryptocurrency and
just last year he made over a million
dollars this this
it's just unbelievable ju and here's the
thing you don't need to know anything
about trading
you don't need to know how to read the
charts it helps if you do but you don't
need to
all you need to do is look for the new
currencies that are actually backed by
decentralized daos decentralized
autonomous organizations
backed by technology that is promising
what is a dao so a decentralized
autonomous organization
for me to put it in simple terms i use
like i used an example of an
app called around the block it doesn't
exist it's all hypothetical
but i i called it around the block
because you know it's
it has a double meaning you know around
it's built on the blockchain
and it's it's also like an uber-based
app where your driver is waiting to pick
you up he's just around the block
so or he's going to take you around the
block whatever so
picture an uber style app the developers
build this technology
and they make it a totally free market
there's no backup there's no
company in the background running things
pulling levers regulating things
regulating what you're allowed to charge
marking up the prices
uh instead they create they create a
token they call it
drivecoin dc so now in order to use this
app in order to
transact in this economy you have to
purchase drive
coin first when you pay a driver you're
paying them in drive coin you're not
paying them in usd you're not paying
them in their in your local native
currency
you're paying them in the token it's
just like when you go to an arcade you
can't put money in the machines
you got to first exchange your money for
a token and then you take those tokens
and you put them in the machines
you see cryptocurrency works the same
way with gaos
decentralized autonomous organization
it's decentralized
means it's not centralized on any any
given server it's all it's a it's a
decentralized peer to peer now that's
all you need to create your own altcoin
so yeah you can create an altcoin
there's numerous ways to create an
altcoin
but then how do you add value a lot of
these there's a lot of scams in all
coins not saying you can't make a money
you can't you can't make money with a
[ __ ] coin because people do it every day
they pump it down that'd be funny you
should make one called a [ __ ] coin
right well people call [ __ ] coins like
any uh
i would say like half of the new tokens
the new all coins that come out
are [ __ ] coins you know people might
have a good idea but
in theory it sounds good but in practice
they don't know how to really build the
tech behind the idea
so all they got is a white paper they
put out a white paper they build a fancy
website
and they sell you on the idea of what it
could be and a lot of times it's a scam
a lot of times it never happens but most
of them like litecoin and
ethereum they're all just spin-offs of
bitcoin btc right right i mean bitcoin
kind of planted the seed
right it definitely paved the way and
educated people on the blockchain
technology so like back to around the
block to understand that what a
decentralized autonomous organization
really is
is you know like
picture the developers build this
technology they're not building a
company they're not forming a c
corporation they're not incorporating it
all it's no government recognized entity
excuse me at all instead they build this
technology
and they allow you as the driver are you
as the writer you as the person who uses
the app
to choose what you're willing to do and
who you're willing to transact with you
as the driver get to set your own rates
you get to choose what you share you
want to share your driving history link
it with the government
api if it exists if it doesn't it should
link it with your criminal background
put post pictures of your car post
pictures of yourself
you know share as much as you want to or
don't share anything at all in a truly
free market
people transact with the people they
want to do business with based on their
credibility and their believability
not based on you know not based on
anything else not based on who the
government
says you're allowed to do business with
or whatever so let the drivers
if you charge 100 a mile of course i'm
not going to hire you to drive me from
point a to point b
i'm going to go with the most economic
right option
so don't mark up the prices at all you
don't
uber makes money by marking up the fares
they make money
went by by charging a premium on what
you're paying the drivers
right and they have hundreds of
thousands of employees to pay in the
background
for what you it's unnecessary build a
technology
that runs itself autonomous it's fully
autonomous
it's automated so you build a technology
that does what it needs to do let people
let everyone who participates in this
choose what they're willing to share
what they're willing to do
force them the only way to transact
inside of this technology
is to first purchase a crypto currency
that's native to your solution
like drivecoin coin is how you make
money as more people transact
on with the currencies more people trade
a currency
that has a fixed volume that has a fixed
amount
like there will only be 20 million of
these
more and more people start using it what
happens to the value
demand increases right the quantity
stays the same
so that drives the price up so now the
developers hold on to
say ten percent they hold into ten
percent of these coins these tokens for
themselves
because they created the technology they
did the work they turned it loose to the
world
they gave it away now if people see this
as a viable option
if they start using this technology if
they start
transacting if they say we know uber is
more expensive because uber is charging
a premium so we actually save money by
hiring people in around the block so if
they start using atb
around the block for for their ride
sharing and their driving
instead of uber now people
have people start buying more drive coin
as people start buying drive coin
the value goes up the developers get
paid they can sell off their drive coin
and convert it to their local native
currency or bitcoin or whatever whenever
they want
but the problem with this is a lot of
the developers can be scammers
so right so the so the problem with [ __ ]
coins or altcoins in general yeah is
it's easy to scam people you know you
sell people you put together an a
nice a pretty website which there's
thousands of templates available
themeforest um you you change the logo
you put together a whitepaper selling
the idea of what you're trying to do
and if it sounds good enough there's
enough money in crypto now where people
are going you can sucker a bunch of
people in the comments stupid is the
term white paper by the way
like the [ __ ] you couldn't call it
trying to make it sound better than it
really is oh it's a white
a white paper what the [ __ ] does that
even mean
information on what the product is what
is it a business plan or something no
i mean yeah and it just it's more like a
product plan it's like what we
what this product the problem it's all
right and you know and
and how we're going to do it okay so if
it's believable people
buy it but white paper makes it sound
more fancy i guess
right so and a lot of a lot of these
coins that's all they have
if you get in pre-sale though like like
my friend ian in orlando
gets in right when these icos these
initial coin offerings launch and become
publicly available
at fractions of a penny so for five
grand you can buy a million of these
things
so you buy a million coins and then they
shoot up to 20 cents
you know almost all of them are 100xing
within a couple of years
so if you if you if you're liquid enough
if you have access to the capital to
actually be able to play
you really can't go wrong because even
if you buy
20 of these or say you buy 10 of these
and nine of them
end up tanking all right you put five
thousand dollars into ten of these
tokens yeah
that's fifty thousand dollars you got a
million of each of these tokens and one
of them hits a dollar
you just made a million dollars on a
fifty thousand dollar investment
a million dollars yeah that's good so is
that what your friend did how did he
make a million bucks
that's more than he put five grand into
he's so he's basically just buying new
tokens tokens that he can purchase for a
fraction of a penny
looking for tokens that are so low but
are promising enough
like i think his criteria he actually
found a
listing on reddit that shows like the
criteria to kind of avoid bad
investments
so he's tr and he's also taking classes
now on how to read the charts he's
getting more into trading
but it's unnecessary that we were just
talking about the other day it's totally
unnecessary you don't need to know how
to trade
you just need to know how to set up an
account set up an account in exchange
like hot bit
i have this wallet called edge wallet
are you familiar with it i haven't used
it but
okay i think there's there's there's a
slew of different wallet
apps you can use right and that's the
thing it's also difficult because
certain wallets when they work with
certain currencies certain exchanges
will only transact with certain
currencies so
you know you're pretty much forced to
use like pancake swap or
or uh you know you know like 10
different five different exchanges just
to be able to get all access to all the
tokens that you want to trade
you can't do it all in one place